hi thank you oh it won't slide okay so
on Monday we had a screening of all the
Academy winners Student Academy winners
and something made me laugh they made me
cry they make me shout they were
brilliant and I couldn't believe that I
can be part of this Academy thank you
very much for making it possible for
bringing all of us together here for
letting me meet those wonderful people
behind this great work to be actually
friends we've done may be for the rest
of the life I hope thank you thank you
to everybody who supported me throughout
this journey of making this film thank
you to Messina brand camp was the first
one to really ask me this important
question what is it all about thank you
the microphones first block the first
one to giggle at my jokes and to believe
in me thank you thank you - Sheila
sofiane is a man tom sito
Mike Patterson Candice rec wrecking her
to all the faculty at USC you were
wonderful
you made me grow you really supported me
you were helpful thank you I was so
lucky to have all of you Thank You Aaron
Gil Martin my brilliant composer who
with your music you took all of these
films so much on another level
so lucky to have had you thank you to my
mom who was always telling me it is okay
to take risks that it is okay to aim
high I wouldn't have been here without
her thank you to my dad yeah to Ava all
of my family who are so supportive who
gave me strength even though they were
far
to really stick to my vision stay true
to myself
Thank You Yola who came here all the way
from your rope was here tonight
representing all of the the family so
let's give her loved life thank you
last thank you Mary Ellen like Polanski
my little family here in the leg who are
always feeding me with food and love
whenever I needed it most and thank you
everybody for coming here